when men are married to women who scream
like this
they just want to die sooner all right
today's topic
tommy lauren something as of recently
has been on my mind
and i consider myself a teacher a helper
um
someone who could possibly inspire
people to be better
so with that being said this is a psa
for all the men out there and all the
boys who think they're men
but they're actually boys this is going
to be the summer of canceling boys
cancel culture you sick of it yet yeah
me too so it's time to cancel cancel
culture
and you know i've got some final
thoughts this is going to be the summer
of canceling boys
almost every single one of them have an
issue with men
and you have to start looking at that
and thinking
if an age range of that many people
including myself
living really all over the country and
being blonde brunette short hair
long hair i mean tan super white super
pen
for a second i got excited i thought she
wanna say super black i was like damn
you got some black friends too no she
went
no super white
super it is not just the guys in los
angeles nashville dallas and it's not
they're not any better in the midwest
they quite frankly i think they're trash
all over this country a lot of men are
trash
a lot of men don't know how to treat
women
they're trash all over this country also
you're also just taking in the people
who are having negative experiences
i'm sure you know people who are happily
married and who are doing fine and
they're good in their relationship
i'm personally single preachers in a
relationship and he has been happy for a
long time
just because i may have a struggle or
two here and there i wouldn't be like
man no man can find love with a woman
because all these women
like fake nails and like what that's
nothing to do with this conversation
i look to my right and i find someone
who's in a loving relationship and is
happy
again this is just a defeatist mentality
because it absolves you of any
responsibility
and it just makes everyone else to blame
for your sense of unhappiness
and i'm not a feminist so please don't
take this as a fitness rant i love
men i think men are great
though we're done she in the same 15
minutes said
i think men are good i think men are
great men are trash
you know what that sweater that i like
that i love i put it in the trash
i didn't fold it i didn't put it i put
it in the trash but that's the sweater
that's twitter it's great it's good it's
hot and everything
like i need it every time i go outside
but it's trash
girl no no no man or trash when we're
saying stuff like that
also be mindful of what kind of
messaging that's sending to
younger people to everyone else who's
watching who are internalizing this
message who are coming to the dating
world
with all this negative stimuli and
they're being like okay men are garbage
if you're trying to build a relationship
with somebody it's probably not a good
idea to go in there with the idea
your garbage prove me wrong jump in the
recycling bin
so i am going to help you the first
thing and i've made notes
by the way i've made notes this is how
invested i am in this all right
next thing value
value value value take that in just
repeat it to yourself until it makes
sense
i value value
i think what thoughts
i ponder the puns as i swim across the
lake
i lay in licks
i cake the cake poetry poetry forward
tree flower tree
i'm swimming through oceans like an
ocean inside of me
slam poetry oh man tommy lauren
yes she's horrend
she thinks she makes sense it feels like
i'm watching the sixth sense
i see dead people i see trash people
i value i see men men are trash
trash thrown out into the garbage bin
ben
is a sin to be a man in this world who's
trash
i lash out out out
at what's that
cloud cloud cloud
value village my [ __ ] vacuum village
wow what what oh value value maybe
she's gonna explain it just put it on
put it on we just you don't know what
value value
means value value no i do
did you just ask me if i knew what value
value is
yeah you had a value value
it sounds like just broken brazilian
english accent value value
going to make efforts to value value why
why why just buy it okay
what she means by value values like if
something is valuable
value it and so she's trying to say this
is what i'm guessing
she's trying to say i'm valuable know my
value which is i think
very arrogant but hey listen maybe she's
got amazing self-esteem maybe maybe
just just put it on we'll see what she
means don't try to guess just
if you want to date a girl that has
nothing going on
then that's fine but please do not mix
in
people like me and my friends who have
something going on
with your other girls they have nothing
going on and by nothing going on i mean
this
i don't there is no job that is
unimportant there is no job that's not
valuable yo listen if you work at a nine
to five that's cool
but i ain't a broke [ __ ] okay so don't
treat me like a girl who works
also keep in mind you never know how
youtube v-ranks us and stuff like that
so if you like us you support what we do
you enjoy the every other day content
that we post for you guys for free for
your enjoyment
leave a like leave a comment check out
the discord join that's right support
we're not asking you for the money we're
asking you to put some clicks like yo
smash that like button how many people
are still not uh uh
watching the videos like 50 50 50 of you
are not subscribed to this
yeah 50 are those window shoppers if you
wanna mix in
people like me and people like my
friends who are go getters who work
really hard
who make their own money who are
talented skilled
ambitious please don't mix us in with
the tatiana's
this is this is one of the fundamental
mistakes that a lot of women make
there are quite a lot of dudes out there
who do not give a sh how ambitious you
are
i'm not saying it's a bad thing i'm not
saying there are some men who are into
it a lot of us
don't care some of us just want to be
shacked up with someone who's going to
be cool
we can count on who we can confide in
and who's going to have her back
for some people that's mostly enough all
right all your ambition all that other
stuff is never going to be more
important than those qualities
all right i need to just know you're
gonna have my back but if i'm vulnerable
around you you're not gonna throw it in
my face
that i can trust you with my secrets
that listen when i hold it down
financially doing all this other stuff
that you're gonna be there for me when i
need it emotionally and all this other
stuff
so all you're talking about we don't
value
but you're mad because our value system
isn't aligned with yours
value value we said it ladies if you
want to go out make sixty hundred fifty
hundred fifty
thousand go ahead do it but doesn't mean
that us men have to value that in you
who are you to impose that on us the
same way we shouldn't tell you ladies
what you should value in men
it'd be like if i got up here right now
and i was like i can't believe
that these women don't value the fact
that i have every episode of great
teacher onizuka
and i'm on manga catalog every day i
have cataloged every episode of dragon
ball z from when goku was a youngin
until when he had his three kids you
don't value value all my anime
like that's that's how it sounds to us
when you're talking well you're trash
then if you don't value that yeah
it's just it's not good logic we don't
want to be there
if that's what you want find them please
for the love of god do not mix us
in with them because we don't want to be
there
and quite frankly we take it as an
insult if we find out that you are also
talking
to five tatianas who have nothing going
on people like me
and my friends are going to be insulted
by that you know what this rant sounds
like
you remember that shooter that went by
the california school
the forever alone the ultimate supreme
gentleman
he he did this video the supreme
gentleman guy he did this video before
he shot up all the women at the school
we'll finally see that i am in truth the
superior one
dress nice i have a nice car a bmw
these sunglasses here for 300
giorgio armani i don't know why you
girls
are so repulsed by me
same position but is the same strain of
thoughts is the same
truth it's the same entitlement it's the
same true true value yes
that's going rough do you know what an
intel is it's an involuntary celibate
yeah
isn't that what she's describing right
now she's an involuntary single person
don't go
don't go to me go to them but if i'm
single
it's because y'all are trash there's a
lot of women out there that i know that
are my good friends
who have amazing jobs who work really
hard but
who can't seem to find a decent guy even
if they go up in age
5 to 10 to 15 years because those guys
all want to be
with 21 year olds who have nothing going
on i don't think she recognized how her
slightly jealous slightly arrogant
slightly
bourjois attitude doesn't come off as
toxic i'm surprised she doesn't
recognize that when i hear this girl
she's not making herself more endearing
as i hear her speech no the more she
talks the more i'm like ugh
you know there's a famous lion i can't
remember who says it's like mark but
he's like
when men are married to women who scream
like this
they just want to die sooner right
that's why men live less
long lives and talking about other women
i thought
those thotianas those those low-class
poor like we got ambitions and we're
rich and you go for a girl
who doesn't have anything you don't
value money and success
what do you not hear yourself
she does she does but she likes it ugh
ugh you you talk you're talking down
about other women
but but men's are trash but men are
trash but here you are disparaging women
who are less fortunate than you are
but okay but men are trash okay those
women
out there are gonna be a lot more
fulfilling to you you're actually gonna
enjoy your time
and if you actually might want a
sustainable and healthy
and stable relationship that's probably
the kind of girl
you're gonna need to find how are you
gonna tell people what they need to find
to be in a stable relationship
when you are single and you don't know
how to get out of your predicament hold
up is she single though
but the way she's talking she is well
she must be because she's talking like
she's single i heard she had a fiancee
guess that she didn't work out
so now she out here guarantee you she's
she's out she's done
tommy lauren calls off engagement to
fiance brandon fickle april 29th
[ __ ] i'm a wizard b let's get this
let's get y'all everyone you're a wizard
harry yeah
you're yo newly single this is like
bitter [ __ ] energy
and she's not even a ghost yet
you know tell them tell them about the
ghost of them the ghost the ghost of the
bitter [ __ ] is the ghost that goes
around like this around and that's not
my bid
that's d ray davis bit he has a bit
called the bitter okay and when there's
a good bit and he's talking about
it's a ghost that's around girls
sometimes and boys
that it just makes you bitter and
jealous and that's what it is let's say
you will have a girl and you're like you
go
okay baby it's me i'm the girl okay uh
i'm about i'm gonna go out and run some
errands all right and you leave
and then the ghost of the bitter become
where is he going
didn't tell you where he was going
i bet he's with that
[Music]
why didn't he say anything
you're really good at that you gotta
you gotta you are your manifestation you
know how to channel that [ __ ]
[ __ ] you talk to spirits i thought this
be you're a wizard yeah that's all the
spirits
okay there gypsy let's go look at like a
living ouija board over here that's
right
um the second thing there is not
a woman out there that wants to be your
pen pal
she doesn't want to get your texts your
good morning texts your good night texts
your random through the day texts
if they don't follow up with a plan to
actually
here's the kicker in person hang out was
it possible that he was just talking to
you
and didn't make any moves because he
just wasn't that into generally when men
are into someone
they're pushy in fact that's something
that women complain about
all the time he moved too fast he was
trying too hard
a pen pal but that also leads me to my
second point
this is me backwards for you guys make
plans
make a plan so if you didn't make a plan
earlier in the day or better yet
a day or two or three in advance i'm not
interested i don't want to hang out
anymore
because that ship has sailed make a plan
i want to hang out with you at this time
it doesn't have to even be a date
i want to see you at this time are you
free at this time
or when are you free i will accommodate
my schedule
to see you listen i'll be honest with
you homegirl
i promise i'll be honest with you if
these guys are not doing these stuff
it's cause they're not that into you
like listen if i'm gearing towards a
relationship but i'm seriously trying to
date people
i'm hitting them up early i'm saying hey
when are you available let's make plans
and i can guarantee you
most men are if a man is into a girl he
wouldn't be like hey you available right
now and the girl's like nah
and then he's like all right well when
are you available that's what he's
always going to ask afterwards almost
all the time or if the girl tells him
hey but i'm free tuesday the guy be like
oh let's try to find a date
but if you think managers will be like
hey girl you free and the girl's like
nah he's like i
deuces he's not into you yes i peace
it's very unfortunate i don't think it's
gonna be fulfilling but i would say to
the men out there
try to maybe find a woman that you can
talk to communicate with
might actually have her [ __ ] together
actually be ambitious
why do people have to be ambitious
that's like such an american point of
view
that thinks that everyone in the world
has to be ambitious some people just
want to leave a peaceful life
some people want to be able to provide
for their family and just be okay with
that
not everyone has to have these lofty
ambitions of wanting to do lavish things
and all that stuff
when i when i left this north american
bubble
it made me realize like just living in
africa living in different parts of
europe that
people don't always live like that
people don't always want to do
all these crazy things even that's just
your arrogant perspective thinking
everyone has to think like you
if i can have a good conversation with
someone yeah that's that's that we could
talk about different
and it's not just with ambition people
ambitious people that you could have a
bunch of
a multitude of of of of
conversation conversation it's with a
lot of different people
you don't have to have a phd like she
said you don't have to be a tv producer
you just have to be blessed me if you're
pleasant
that is half the battle if you have
something to say
you're chill this is like you're
ambitious but you're nagging
god damn have you talked to retirees and
old people they have someone not so much
knowledge to offer
yeah it's interesting to talk to them
yeah they're not super ambitious oh
do i should be like hey [ __ ] where are
you trying to go in life 86 come on pete
this just sounds dumb the next thing on
my list is this consistency
it really does not help me or my friends
or any woman in general
if you are really cool and you're really
interested when you first start talking
to them
and then give it three four five days
and all of a sudden you're not
consistent anymore
you don't make plans you don't really
care you kind of fade in and out you're
talking to five other thought tiana's
consistency is important because he's
not interested in you that's it
take your cues sometimes silence
is louder than talking maybe maybe
maybe you're consistent yeah and nagging
and it just dim his light he's just dead
you sucked it all out
it's like it's like it's like if your
father ran out at you you wouldn't be
like man where is he
why isn't he showing it nigga's not
interested
he bombs okay
sorry tell you guys there's a whole
bunch of viewers like thanks dad
i'm sorry but like sometimes their
absence
is very telling as well was the dad
example too far i
i ain't mad at it okay you know why why
because your dad was present no because
it was true true
i guess hey listen that response i value
value
any grown woman that refers to real
women as thoughtianas
already is just starting off on a bad
foot it's like women who you mean in
person and they're like
l-o-l immediately that is one of the
biggest
turn offs i have ever seen lmao
are you for real uh that was exactly
the enlightenment that i thought it
would bring uh
nada don't give away control
of your situation to the world around
you
there's you gain nothing by sitting
there and being like everyone else is
the problem
i'm here well then you're still where
you were before and now you complain so
you push people further away
it's never going to work out well for
you so focus on the things that you can
control and try to improve on that
all right if you've got some trauma that
makes you unable to connect with other
people
then go see a shrink if you are somebody
who's distrusting a people
find a way to work through that before
you jump into something but there's no
sense in looking at the world like
everything is evil
i can't give you guys advices on how to
date and this and that it wasn't because
i'm not
it's not my reality right so i'm not
gonna sit out there and be like you know
what you guys should do you should do
it's not my reality i don't know i don't
know the works of it
i've been out of the game for a long ass
time so i don't know i don't know
but i know that one thing i know like
you said being bitter is not one of them
and that's not even for dating that's
for anything looking for a job
uh exceeding your in your job trying to
find
um more accomplishment trying to
grow go through the ladders of life
being bitter
is never a solution i checked out a long
ass time ago from that video
we're done cool all right well if you
guys value value leave a comment in the
comments below
we want to hear from you put a comment
in the comments yes that's right comment
the comments comment the comments
[Music]
first question for men if you like a
girl if you're even somewhat interested
in a girl
you need to ask yourself this question
are you single
no i don't mean are you kind of single
seeing five people
dating somebody still kind of in a
relationship
kind of broken up kind of on again off
again kind of married
kind of divorced are you actually single
single
that means single you have nobody you
have no complications you have no
attachments
you are actually single that is the
first question believe it or not that
needs to be asked
and ladies you should be asking it
because in 2020
it's not a given anymore that a guy
that's actively pursuing you is actually
single
so that's the first thing so you're
gonna act like women don't do that
okay yeah men of trash because this
yeah therefore women are trashed because
of this too as well
it's kind of like okay so yeah but women
don't do it as much no no don't
women do it as much and you know what
i'm glad
because you know that's equality you
have to understand as well that go ahead
when you have a good experience you're
going to talk about it
about two to three times
when you have a bad example a bad
experience
you're going to be talking about it 10
times to 15 times
right we the weight of me the the brain
the mat that
the human brain works is we latch on to
negative things that happen example i
was doing a show
and it was an arena it was a theater
that had a thousand two hundred people
right twelve hundred muff
there was one person front row arm cross
arms cross me mugging not laughing at a
single joke
everybody else was laughing but i was
like man what the hell is this
what the hell is this guy not like what
the hell is his problem who
cares you have 1199
people laughing and i'm fixated on this
dude and we all
we we do that a lot we're gonna be like
what the
when we just gonna forget all these
people laughing and having a good time
so a lot of times sometimes whenever
people
bad experiences we remember the bad
experiences more than we remember the
good ones
and also the fact that whenever
something happens to you something bad
happens to you
and when you tell that story you depict
yourself as the hero so you think it's
all them not you